what's your fat guy food it's gotta be
pizza yeah it's in a food if if you dude
that's my vice man if you don't like
pizza there one person told me they
didn't like pizza and i don't like them
i don't like people like i don't trust i
don't trust people
pizza is incredible yeah yeah even bad
pizza like it's fine it's and it's
simple when [ __ ] is good dude it's good
pizzas [ __ ] yeah pizza's good i'm
telling you even shitty pizza sometimes
you have a shitty piece of pizza
somewhere like you know in new york
sometimes you'll have those bars they'll
give you a little personal pizza with a
beer or whatever and even those you're
like it's okay i fantasized about just
going crazy at pizza hut one day
just like that that was your question
just the [ __ ] like the gross you know
it's gross so you know after a pie it's
going to be disgusting but just
there was something about like the dough
and the dirtiness of it yeah yeah you're
a fat bad boy
the dirty you're a fat little bad boy
i'm a bad boy
you call pizza like i'm a fat little
dirty boy
we serve food here sir